it's that time of the year again caps
and gowns
pomp and circumstance the best four
years of your life officially behind you
and ahead of you a ton of death
congratulations class of 2016
you're officially screwed I have on the
order of $40,000 in debt something like
six seven thousand dollars alone thirty
forty thousand I mean I don't know the
exact number but I know it's over twenty
five thousand after four years of
attending University of California
Berkeley I will 150,000 or between
150,000 to 200,000 dollars last year's
class of 2015 was sent off into the
world as the most indebted class in
history owing more than an average of a
whopping thirty five thousand dollars
and they're not alone seventy-one
percent of college kids today are taking
out student loans for an undergraduate
degree which now costs more than a
hundred thousand dollars on average
they're joining the forty million people
in this country that are burdened with
student debt and with wages stagnant
that means it's a lot harder to settle
down buy a house to start a family or
save for retirement more and more people
are pushing these things further and
further back because they're still
paying off the tuition 21 years after
graduating
maybe that's why 43 percent of folks
with government student loans aren't
making their payments wasn't College
supposed to help you get ahead in life
not hold you back back when I attended
UC Berkeley in-state tuition was less
than $6,000 a year now it's thirteen
thousand five hundred dollars so how did
things get so bad well the recession has
played a role with states using it as an
excuse to slash higher education budgets
in 2015 the average state was spending
20% less per student than in 2007 before
the financial crisis that means
universities are raising tuition fees to
make up the difference but that's not
the only explanation for why getting a
degree comes with loans these days while
students might be struggling many
university presidents
Columbia University's president took
home 4.6 million dollars in 2015
even some public schools which are
funded by the taxpayer have paid
presidents over a million dollars a year
and let's not forget about football
coaches the top two highest-paid coaches
made over seven million dollars each
while University staff overall has
increased professors aren't the people
being hired as primarily administrative
staff since the mid 1970s the number of
non teaching employees has grown by 369
percent compared to just 23% for
full-time faculty altogether students
who went to college in the u.s. Oh 845
billion dollars and it's a lucrative
business for the federal government
which owns most of that debt but is
getting an education have to be this
expensive check out what this American
student in Germany had to say you get
much more value for your money here you
hardly pay anything and you get an
education that is I would say on the
same level if not better than many
American universities maybe it's time to
figure out how we can make college
affordable without having to go abroad
you